good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday that's right
it's Friday and your girlies are singing
together on tune because we are together
in our Florida Studio hey Jax how you
doing good because not only is it Friday
but it's also stride day for the first
time in I want to say months Bryce and
strice are on the show and this is
giving me a joie de Viva like no other
that I knew I was missing but I've tried
to suppress because Bryce didn't want to
work with his mommy what can you do but
then he saw Theo in studio so he was
like I'm not going to be bested by this
guy by my own cousin by my own cousin
you know he's with his mommy well Theo
and I are both thrilled honored and
really feeling very welcomed here at
your home and your studio so thank you
so much for having us we're so happy to
have you how has your time been so far
just simply delightful I really forgot
what it's like to reside in the same
residence as roldadini and I can just
it's such a joy it is such a joy
especially when he's like yearning for
me in the way that he is I think and I'm
not even being crazy I'm so glad you
were there because like you know that
Harry full-on said my name
yeah he's trying to work it out yeah
like I was like Claudia Claudia and he
was like
she'll be sounding it out obviously I
have like the worst name in which my
name was Sarah sometimes like you know
we're just one syllable Sarah and two or
like
something really well he says like a lot
of Google so I wish my name was like
Greta two syllables
gab gab like just call me gab from now
on Auntie gab okay I've Got The Gift of
Gab and I'm Auntie gab and t-gab
speaking of NT hero it's Midnight's
release day we'll talk about it in the
Fast Five so I don't want to get into it
and we actually did something really fun
last time oh yeah patreon we were trying
to wait up till midnight so hard and
Claudia had gotten reached out to from
instacart and they send like this little
care package to help us wait up we
thought it was going to be things in
which to snack no they gave us
ingredients instead it was things in
which debate so Margo realized the
ingredients that they sent were Taylor's
famous cookie recipe for chai sugar
cookies and we made them we vlogged the
whole experience and honestly it was a
wild ride and honestly you just have to
see it we won't even tease the results
because it's an experience that you need
to experience at patreon.com the toast
that video should be up today sometime
this weekend yeah yeah I'll get it I'll
get it out we'll turn her out we're
constantly churning out content here
constantly like that's the thing when
you come it's so much fun but then we
this house just turns into a Content
Farm I know we're like literally one of
those like Tick Tock houses when we're
together like we make so many tick tocks
we Vlog we podcast we're literally the
hype house we are the high pass we're
the stress house that would be our name
we should invite like a bunch of dog
influencers to live with us in the
stress house and we'll start like our
own page and stuff mystery Butters
Magnolia yeah Magnolia is here too so
it's been really I mean only got here
last night but it's just been absolutely
Heavenly obviously I was able to see
mckaylaard roldini and our new nephew
which was such a delight like I really
miss the kids so much especially the
kids that I've previously known you know
the new baby I don't really know him yet
um but Michael are enrolled like I know
them so well I have them booked to
memory that every change I guess I'm
gonna kill a lot of bug bite like what
who fine bring that mosquito to me death
to that mosquito how dare he yeah
although I can understand because I've
often been inclined to take a bite out
of Michaela too exactly miss her already
so it's been fabulous I'm so excited to
be here I have no plans to go home so
that's fabulous I've been eating my way
through your house we have so many
delicious snacks things I shopped for
you and I'm also just like always
cooking and baking now it's like someone
who just has like a tupperware with some
fresh muffins on the microwave oh you
know what I was just remembered a story
that I wanted to ask you to do so if
there's anything that you can um yes
there is something that you can bump
there was a like the fifth Story was
just gonna be like a small update that I
most wanted to share it now uh the crown
will be making a disclaimer oh okay that
is important yeah it's not like the best
most like
it just if you didn't know the backstory
I'd be like I thought it would just be
like them writing you know this is based
on Queen Elizabeth like duh okay I might
have spoken because the story that I
wanted to share like was going around on
social media but like no one's written
it up so I'll just share it as a fit
story okay those are my favorite kinds
of stories like why do we need to wait
for someone to write like a lukewarm
take on a story when like you're on the
pulse I'm not gonna say we say you're on
the post thank you so much that's so
nice and we are on the pulse
Depends for the topic yeah of course
depends on the day for me yeah what I
had going on
um this week I'm not on the pulse I've
been like so busy every single day like
I literally am still in my makeup and
Toes outfit until like 10 p.m right
right one thing about me is that I'm
prioritizing skincare like I take my
makeup off in the studio I literally
that's how busy I am like I don't have
the time to wipe Mama Tings and also I
don't like to wipe my makeup off with a
makeup remover and then not wash my face
after I know I know on tour like I got
used to it because I could put them in a
long car ride like I'm just gonna take
my makeup off you know yeah also that's
life on the road for you though redheads
merch is still available at
shopmorningtoast.com I've seen a lot of
redheads have gotten their merch I'm so
happy for you guys I've been wearing
merch all week and it's so gorgeous and
sickening so head over to
shopmorningtoast.com get yourself a
little something and it's my favorite
thing about the redheads merch I said
this on my q a but maybe people don't
listen with sound on my Instagram
stories well you don't so um no no
that's that wasn't shade it's like maybe
you're like me and you don't maybe yeah
um is that it's such a great
conversation starter yes because people
will see it and some of it says the
redhead some says the redheads book club
but either white people will be like
what's that and it's a great way to meet
someone to meet someone to get in a
conversation about books and like when I
meet a fellow reader whether I know them
so well or I don't know them at all like
we can officially talk for an hour I
completely one of my Goodreads I'm going
through my faves I'm asking yourself and
I'm asking for Rex so that's what I love
about the redheads and of course like to
spot a redhead in the wild simpatico
speaking of books I am like almost done
maybe 70 of the way through with the it
ends with a sequel it starts with us and
it's good I mean I feel like I've
evolved a little bit like past my Coho
phase but she still slaps like she
writes a good story you really care
about the characters so it's it's filled
with drama it's really good I heard um
Rach parcel didn't like it
she said on her Instagram at the beach
well the thing is and I feel like Rachel
parcel and I like have a very similar
we're always sharing wrecks with one
another
Colleen Hoover is the author that gets
you into like romance books like spicy
novels the kids are calling it smut now
um why no that's just like what you call
like book porn I don't know it is a
stand for something spicy sexy music
under toes I don't know you need so
unique I don't know
um and so Coho Colleen Hoover books are
really the books that like get you into
that and then you find like Tessa Bailey
and Lucy score and then once you get
deep into it like you go back and read
Coho and like it doesn't slap like it
used to because it's really like an
entry point it's a Gateway yeah that's
how I feel I don't know if that's how
rage feels yeah I feel like for rage
what she said like it wasn't steamy
enough right no it's by the way I'm like
70 of the way through and there was like
maybe like half a steamy scene but for
me that's not why I'm reading this book
like I'm reading this book because I
really loved this story and the
characters and I Want To Know How It
Ends got it and I love Adam I read it if
I liked it ends with us yeah okay cool
yeah it's and it's very easy to get
through on the way here I think I got
through like 50 okay I will I need to
finish the empress I was going to treat
myself last night but then I passed out
um and then I I need to get into some
more books I was going to start this new
book that's on like recently came out
it's called The Princess
um the princess papers or something like
that it's not on fiction sounds like a
literal Disney Channel original no but
it's written by a man and it's about
like this princess Countess who became a
spy during World War II it's a true
story one thing about me is like I do
not [ __ ] with books written by men I
know like the last book I read by a man
was the silent patient and it Loki stunk
especially for how much hype it has the
silent patient I personally think is not
I wanted to pull my [ __ ] hair out
people like Quake over it and it's not a
bad book but like Quake worthy it ain't
no and like the big twist spoiler alert
oh really don't say whatever okay well
the big twist is so stupid and not
believable I read the book and I'm like
what is the big twist yeah and it was
like that and it had the way that he was
yeah you said we're not gonna go you
said three words
um yeah I'm like sure
sure Theo sure that was his name yeah so
it wasn't it wasn't my cup of tea and I
just I really I cannot recall the last
book I read by a man unless it's a
celebrity Memoir like Howard Stern Andy
Cohen but it's just not for me like
and I say this all the time like I think
there are specific roles for women I
think there's specific roles for men and
like for me like you're a male author no
you're not I don't know I feel like the
books not to like I mostly read books by
women I'm only really interested in the
books that women write they write about
women I'm a woman I also hate reading
about women from a man 100 because it's
like you don't know the woman but I also
kind of sometimes hate reading about men
from a women's point of view like what
world are you living in no agree it's
not happening no for anyone no 100 but I
think the good thing about reading about
a man from a woman's perspective it's
like it's wishful thinking it's fantasy
yeah like we wish men were like that so
there's fun in it but reading a man
right about a woman it's like what the
[ __ ] do you know yeah but to eat a man
like write about a romance I feel like
it's more interesting for women
sometimes perhaps maybe that's why
people like Nicholas Sparks Perhaps
Perhaps well like I'm so over Nicholas
Sparks oh my God yeah NoHo literally
buried him Clips feet in the ground
eclipsed him
I was gonna say the books that I do read
by men maybe because like they're real
like I would only read a book by man if
it was really recommended or something
like they're really good books yeah like
Amar tolls you know like for me books
are like Gary Genetti you know kazuo
ishiguro Clara and the Sun not for me
nothing to see here Kevin Wilson like
chef's kiss yeah that's true actually I
guess that's the last book I read by a
man
no for real oh no and the silent patient
yeah
so it's just like men go crunch your
numbers let us handle the books okay
also I did read the interview with coho
in the New York Times oh what did you
think and I thought it was really great
um to hear from this woman who's become
like so prevalent in pop culture but
under the mainstream radar yeah and I
loved hearing from her and it's just so
crazy how much her life has changed in
like the last few years her first book
was self-published like you should read
it slammed oh I haven't read it like
that was the first book she put out on
Amazon self-publishing oh that's amazing
and then
um it just really snowballed let me ask
you something in the profile because you
know I only skimmed like The Tick Tock
Recaps did they mention the impact of
tick tock on her business what did they
say
um that she's just like big on Tick Tock
and the pandemic right and like Tick
Tock actually influences Book Sales yes
and also during the pandemic and we had
posted this on the redheads Instagram
when it happened so if you follow us
like you're always in the know Colleen
like felt like she was it was the
beginning of the pandemic and she was
like you know why lot of people's jobs
are impacted but like authors jobs
aren't and I'm going to give my books
out for free on uh ebooks or whatever
wow you could download them for free oh
wow so she did like five books for free
and so people would read them because
then they're like let me go to co-host
so it actually turn out to be like a
smart marketing thing but I don't think
that's how she meant it at all no that's
so nice yes oh wow I love her I'm so
happy for her and her success you'd love
to see women in publishing thriving
um so we've got a great show we do we've
got Fast Five no TV recap but we're just
going to take it slow chill it's Friday
I'm not in a rush and more importantly
it's dry day can I talk about something
something that has come with my weight
loss
um that I never expected was I guess I
didn't realize and you can like go back
and watch old episodes like I was
physically unable to cross my legs
because my belly got in the way like a
pregnant person can't yeah the way I'm
obsessed with crossing my legs I have I
I don't know if anyone on the planet can
relate to this I have a newfound
obsession with you you're gonna find me
on your couch with my legs crossed
that's how I live my life my legs are
always crossed but like it does get like
after a few like you got to switch Yeah
it's like a little fatigued if you ever
catch me on the toast like that's what
I'm doing the whole time like the way I
didn't even realize I was
physically enable unable to cross my
life this is such a gorgeous look so
slender so slender but the way that I
cross my legs like I'm clenching like
I'm it's so tight I don't even like
realize that's like everything with me
I'm like drop your shoulders unclench
your jaw relax sometimes I got like
passionate on the toes and I'm like why
are you making a fist yeah no sometimes
I'll be like literally laying in my bed
watching tick tocks I'm like holy [ __ ]
I'm holding so much tension in my jaw
like calm the [ __ ] down I'll be trying
to fall asleep and I'm like unclenched
unclenched unclenched yeah no I'm
constantly clenching clenchio plenchio
mcclinchia mcclinch yeah
um so I feel like without further did it
do where are you right here being
perfect angels just as you should be it
is time for the fast five stories that
you need to know
Just Go With It with it not everyone
needs to comment be commented on but
like um when it's the right one we'll
know like I know that's not it okay of
course I know maybe do better
maybe do better I just I could spend
time thinking about it maybe you should
but I I I just wanted to come to me
naturally as most things do on the show
today's episode is sponsored by match
the dating app it's
oh my God excuse me sorry
match dating app is pretty much
everything of the sort because the most
important relationship you have is with
yourself so in a world where you can
choose to do anything be anyone Choose
Yourself first dating someone who knows
what they want and won't settle for less
that is sexy as hell so whatever you're
into whether it's crypto
ghosts I don't know everyone has
different interests
I feel like it's really important that
you know yourself really well before you
dive into a relationship and so match
really supports that theory of getting
to know yourself because you can't
really give yourself to someone until
you really can give yourself to you yeah
and until you know yourself right and
how can you expect someone else to and
being single is such a great time for
that like really spending time getting
to know when you're yourself so when the
time comes that you're ready to like
give yourself to someone or join match
like you have well thought out answers
like you know who you are and I feel
like people are really attracted to that
energy like someone who knows themselves
who's confident who knows exactly what
they want who's not just willing to like
go along with anything like to know know
thyself who was it Shakespeare I'll
Google it while you continue letting us
know about match so match is really
encouraging you guys to be your own best
friend with benefits take yourself out
to dinner take yourself home
you can stimulate yourself you don't
need someone else to stimulate you
so if you want to do you which I think
you do want to did it did it do you you
already know the best relationships show
up when you show up for yourself first
so there's never been a better time to
try match you can download the match app
today I know a lot of people who've had
major success with the match app so many
toasters have told me about their
experiences a lot of their like
long-term Partners husbands and
girlfriends and wives they have met on
Match and I feel like match is a really
trusted source for like the right kind
of people and Max is just encouraging
you to get out there and truly like look
out for number one that's you and to
find serious people looking for serious
relationships also know thyself is an
ancient Greek aphorism but Socrates did
say to know thyself is the beginning of
wisdom classic Socrates so download the
match app today and let us know what
happens because the world is you're
oyster and the possibilities are endless
and start living your own real life Coho
book 100 100 first story one word
midnights periods new album came out
last night I passed out at 11 40. I was
waiting up so hard with Margo and then
Margo [ __ ] fell asleep and she was
the one being like a general the whole
night like we have to stay up and then I
turned around this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
asleep
we were reading in my bed and she's
literally talking in her sleep I'm like
what'd you say and then I realized she's
asleep she goes oh really yeah we're
gonna do that okay that's what she said
in her sleep oh my God and then I was
like are you sleeping and she didn't say
anything so I was like oh my God she's
[ __ ] asleep so then I was like all
right well I'm not gonna wait up alone
so I passed out too and then also it's
not just waiting up till midnight it's
then listening to the whole hour another
hour and then like once I'm up at one
o'clock she had another announcement at
3am which was seven more songs right so
I'm like you know what this can wait
till tomorrow and I woke up early anyway
I woke up at like 6 30 because Bryce
strutted and sauntered into my room they
scared the [ __ ] out of me and my leg was
hurting me like in my sleep so I just
woke up and I was fine with it because
then I got to lay in bed for like two
hours and listened to the album I
haven't made it through all the
additional seven songs and probably at
like 15 or 16 out of 20. and people are
of course you know ranking them sharing
their favorite Snippets and I just need
everyone to calm the [ __ ] down like I
Taylor doesn't work for years on works
of art for you like rank them in less
than 12 hours and like digest it and
poop it out in one day and the thing
about Taylor's music is like it ages it
ages exactly and there are songs like
you might have looked past like I feel
like when I was obsessed with reputation
I used to skip King Of My Heart Like
endlessly and it's now my belief that's
the best song in the album like they
take time to settle in and like
different phases of your life where you
feel like you can start to relate to
different songs so obviously there's a
few that stand out like anti-hero
obviously because the ante and it's the
lead single it's the lead single and
it's so good and it's a song that truly
everyone can relate to because like
every person has been up at night like
thinking the worst things about
themselves like oh man everyone thinks
I'm annoying everyone thinks I'm ugly
everyone thinks I'm fat and like that's
what the whole message of the song and
the music video is and it's so relatable
and it's a Bop like like it's a
certified Bop
I was gonna sing it but like I can't
even remember it but it's like
I literally can't remember it because
I'm normal
um karma is also a song that really
stands out one because you know there is
this Taylor Swift conspiracy theory
amongst her fans that before reputation
and the whole Kim Kardashian thing
happened she was gearing up to release
an album called karma oh and it's like
this mysterious album that was never
released because then she had had to
follow it up with reputation since she
released a single called karma I think
like addressing the fact that like we're
all clowns and there was never an album
but the song is there was that there was
never an album yeah like she wouldn't
name a song Karma if she had a whole
album called karma you know I think she
had an album that I don't think was
called karma got it well that's possible
I don't think it was at that stage of
branding yet yeah that's possible well
the song car was so good it's just like
I think and I think they were all songs
about Calvin Harris and then he turned
out to be a big loser yeah so she's like
you don't describe an album scrap well I
think it's obviously about Scott
warshadow there's a lot of the songs
that feel like they're about like the
whole betrayal because like and I feel
like a lot of people think like Taylor
like get over it like whatever you're
moving on you're really releasing but
like there are just some things in life
that you can't get over like and for her
I think her cancellation was one of them
and like no sorry not yeah her
cancellation but also the Scott Works
had a thing
um and I think a lot of people sorry I'm
misspeaking I think a lot of people want
her to be like Get over the Kanye thing
um because yeah like it was so many
years ago but like being dragged on the
internet like by the entire universe
like that that doesn't go away and as
somebody who's been there I can relate
like keep singing about it like I
appreciate it because like I feel the
same way about my cancellation still
right and also like she's someone who
has a lot of feelings and emotions and
that's one of the biggest things that
can happen to a person you know she
writes five songs about a guy who looked
at her in the hallway in high school
Enchanted yeah so like the whole world
turned on her she's gonna write 50
[ __ ] songs no and it's such a layered
experience from an emotional point of
view and how far away you get from it
like in the beginning there's all of
that like it's really the stages of
almost grief because then it comes back
and like there are years later where
you're still so mad about it right but
also in years later you might reflect on
it feel differently new song yeah no
totally so I don't mind like a lot of
people are like Get over the thing no
like I totally understand it the songs
are about a lot of different things a
lot about Joe Alwyn like a lot about how
she's just so [ __ ] happy which is so
nice there is a song would have could
have should have that a lot of people
think is about John Mayer
um and again a lot about the Scott
borchetta the Betrayal stealing her work
stealing her youth
um so again I don't really feel like
it's fair to give like I'll have a lot
more to say on Monday if we listen to it
a lot this weekend which I presume that
we will put on the Sonos we could put it
on the Sonos but I just need everyone to
chill like for real like calm down
everyone's like clay give us your
rankings how like that would be so
it would be fraudulent on my part it
would and one thing about me I'm a lot
of things I'm not a fraudulent person
all you can say at this point is if
there are any songs that just jumped out
at you when you first when you heard it
you were like oh my gosh this is a Bop I
don't feel that way about any of the
songs really from this album because
they're like a little more involved and
I think eventually you have to live with
them but sometimes I do hear songs like
that new Shania Twain song the first
time I heard it I'm like certified Bob
waking up dreaming
do you know I adore you oh my God I love
that song yeah there's nothing like that
I do on the album no no it's not that
kind of out it's not that kind of album
because it's not like singles with
different hits It's like a true work of
art it's like a it's meant to be
listened to in full
um so I agree there aren't like you know
ones that stand out as like I'm gonna
listen to this at the club but I wasn't
sure what the vibe was going to be I had
a feeling it would be exactly what it is
which is very like synth like yeah like
Maggie Rogers would be the reference
Lana Del Rey I don't really know Lana
Del Rey I have to say the Lana Del Rey
song might be my least favorite and one
thing that I love about Taylor is like
oh I'm gonna have a huge artist on my
album no you're gonna I'm gonna have a
huge artist on my album you're not gonna
hear anything they say like they're
always in the background they're like
who the [ __ ] heard Chris Stapleton on I
bet you think about me you didn't hear
hame on nobody no crime and you're
certainly not hearing Lana Del Rey on
snow on the beach that's what I love
about her humbling big artists for sure
but like for me that song Nobody no
crime is a crime I know you don't like
it I love it oh my God I was listening
to the album while I was baking the
other day I mean I baked once and it's
your personality I don't know it's like
all the muffins I'm talking about all
the times I was making it's like oh this
one time
um I was listening to that album and
it's I had to actually like wash my
hands and press it uh I don't mind it at
all I like it I hate it I hate it SD
sisters gonna swish she was with me
I like it I like it eight and a lot of
people um there's a song called
vigilante [ __ ] oh that's the one I got
up to in the album and I like this song
but it's like very much you need to be
in that mood you need to be it's like a
story she's telling and a lot of people
think it's like oh she delivered proof
of scooter bronze Affair to Yael people
are so you're reaching like she's
obviously if we learned anything since
Taylor Swift has now been in a sexy or
happy relationship it's like a lot of
the songs she writes are not even about
herself and she said that it's about
random thoughts she has books movies she
wrote that she wrote uh
as the traffic lights if it'll be all
right they say I what is the song is
that
whatever that one
um death by Thousand Cuts is about that
uh Gina Rodriguez Netflix movie like she
pulls references because like she's not
out and about having you know Whirlwind
romances anymore her life is now settled
so I would appreciate if everyone like
would stop looking for like some of the
songs are just like maybe not about her
and I just feel like people are reaching
yeah
so we'll continue to listen to the album
I only got up to vigilante [ __ ] which I
was enjoying but I was like I need to be
in like a sassier mood not just like me
trying to get ready for this yeah and
start my day the music video for
anti-hero is so good though like it's
she looks so stunning she looks like so
mature it's so funny because we don't
really see her every day we see her
literally like four times a year so she
really like grows up every time we see
her now she looks like a woman like she
looks great she looks like a movie
that's like a real movie yeah uh
question for you that I was thinking
about what would you consider her Worst
Album I know debut debut okay
and I love her but that's just like it's
not bad by any means I think Taylor
Swift's Worst Album is like some of the
best of course it's like I'm not gonna
drag anyone but okay take out debut just
because it's not fair to compare it like
sonically she made it like in her
bedroom yeah sonically right and I
actually think debut would benefit the
most from being re-recorded yeah because
she but she's been doing them the same
still no but like the sound quality yeah
like okay so we have debut we have
um Fearless Speak Now red
well you know people are not gonna like
what I have to say 1989 reputation lover
it's not folklore it's not Evermore it's
too soon to tell with midnights
um it's not lover I like and this is a
unique POV that I have like personally
like I do not like love I'm never gonna
go to like out of my way to listen to
reputation which is so crazy because I
know it's so many people's favorites I
think reputation was ahead of its time
and I love it I don't and I think I mean
I love it but you know and as a work of
art like I think it's Perfection I
wouldn't change a hair on a Ted there
are so many songs on lover that I love
um but as a body I agree I think it was
it felt so contrived like the whole
aesthetic and like just she went from
being like so intense and like
revengeful to being like like Ken it
just felt like so and I know she it
doesn't feel cohesive I I thought that
just felt like too phony you know okay I
agree that some of her best songs are on
lover but I do agree like at a glance
from The Big Bang Theory like as a work
of art as a body of work it doesn't feel
cohesive and it doesn't feel complete
yeah and just like a little too
manufactured with all the like Instagram
stuff that went around I agree I agree
that wasn't my favorite era by any means
yeah that wasn't my favorite era and you
have to think about the era as well it's
so important to know like when I
criticize a work something that's
criticizing like a 99 versus in a
hundred yeah like it's still better than
half the
95 of the [ __ ] that gets released today
so like just that that scale is
important to keep in mind because I'm
not by mean saying her Worst Album is
there's a bad song on it like it's still
better than anything I've ever heard in
my life yeah I should do a treadmill too
reputation that would be a good it's a
great uh album to get you going yeah
okay maybe we'll do it together
you know what I've been doing a little
bit of and I've known about this for
years because it came out years ago but
I've been implementing it into my
workout 12 3 30. from Tick Tock yeah of
course so what I'll do is it really
works it really works and it's really
hard so I'll do I'll go 12 incline three
speed for 10 minutes not 30 then I do
five minutes jogging no walking in
between and then another 10 minutes of
12 3 and then another five minute jog
yeah 3 30 is like a magic they say like
it literally will get you toned and fit
yeah you can feel your course working do
they talk about if you're supposed to
hold on to the treadmill I know you
probably shouldn't but you're so asking
the wrong girl like we are The Tick Tock
girl yeah but I don't watch the 12
through 30 videos in full okay I go back
and forth because sometimes I need help
just enough to know like that it's
popular but not enough to actually care
got it okay cool are you ready for our
next story like a really big news in
world of Pop Culture e-news is returning
on November 14th with new co-host Adrian
nylon Haughton and Justin Sylvester yes
yes e announced yesterday that E news
which is premiering Monday November 14th
at 11 30 p.m what happened to 7 and 11
what happened to 7 and 11. who is
watching e-news at 11 30. we'll be
they're doing it's like late night now
is that pacific time I think it's
eastern okay we'll be executive produced
by veteran TV producers John Redmond and
John Pascarella the Monday through
Thursday broadcast we'll have an uh
emphasis on Celebrity friendly
back-based reporting and serve as a
platform for personalities to connect
with their fans Tracy Wilson the EDP of
NBC Universal said e-news has a long
history of entertainment news excellence
and we are excited to bring the show
back and continue its Legacy John and
John are strategic respected executive
producers with stellar reputations and
Justin and Adrian are charismatic
seasoned host with a genuine interest in
pop culture this is the perfect team to
bring a fresh take to this franchise I
actually completely agree guys were told
I think they couldn't have picked two
better people one Justin is loved by the
audiences he's such a your professional
celebrities love him Adrian Baylon comes
with like another audience from The Reel
she's very funny and personable I feel
like a lot of celebrities like know her
personally and really like her too so I
think they couldn't have chose two
better hosts I don't know why E news
went off when everyone off the air
because when it was literally the only
asset that he had in its Arsenal like
they lost Kardashians and they just
decided to like wipe the Slate clean and
it was the dumbest idea because E news
is like such a respected
program and I feel like of all the
programs like Access Hollywood inside
everyone would choose to watch E news
and they just got rid of it it was so
random and stupid yeah so I'm thrilled
for Justin mostly because and for the
e-news viewers because they deserve more
Justin and yeah for the E audience like
we need Justin and we need him now I am
curious though like why it wasn't Morgan
and Justin yeah because they're like the
two favorites from me maybe they're
trying to you know expand because I
don't think as much as we love daily pop
and Nellie Papa they must not have had
huge ratings if if they got canceled so
maybe they're just trying to switch it
up to bring in new audiences like yeah
they were trying the same couple of
people for so many years and obviously
it didn't work and maybe like they'll do
another talking head show that with
Morgan at the helm but like they had two
really great talents and so to put them
together in one program it's like okay
then what would we do next yeah I'm
happy for Justin because I feel like you
know that he doesn't have to wake up so
early anymore no he like he had no
social life like when I come to town I'm
like when I get drinks he's like yeah
how's five o'clock I'm like oh what no
like he would literally have to be on a
lot of like five or six yeah no and so
this is gonna be 11 30. it's gonna be
like late night like why is it live
I think so
that's a good question that is a good
question
11 30 p.m so that means he would film at
8 30 PM which means he's done at 9 30
like date 10 o'clock 10 o'clock date
dinner yeah I'm happy for him and
Justin's just very talented and I feel
like yeah I feel like obviously he will
be like I feel like we'll be watching
him on the Today Show like when we're in
our 50s so I'm like whatever we can do
to get him there you know yeah he will
do great things and this is just another
step yeah and finally like this is the I
think the first time in maybe three
years we're reporting on something E
news did and not dragging them to filth
yeah but and then you also have to keep
in mind they have that Instagram account
that like has just been like an
Instagram account for like an influencer
for the last two years news yes since he
went away E news went away oh yeah and
it's still called E news right yeah yeah
well now it makes sense yeah Theo
snoring and having a crazy dream
sometimes Theo will run in his sleep
does Bruno ever do that no like he'll he
obviously won't get up but his legs will
like oh interesting no my baby boy
doesn't do it he lays dormant
yeah he does some cute things you know
just a few just a few he has his own
personal touches but then you find out
that every dog does them too okay
um speaking of
personal touches the next story is
sponsored by bowling Branch so I'm
thrilled to be here at Jackie's house
because nothing much has changed I have
bowl and bread sheets at my home
actually just got some new new stuff
from them and I have bowling Branch your
attacking so I'm sleeping like a baby no
matter where I go thanks to the bowling
Branch signature hem sheets their
best-selling set for a good reason
they're made from the highest quality
threads for Superior softness and a
better night's sleep they have over 25
000 Rave customer reviews and Counting
they're buttery soft super breathable
cozy and they're perfect for every
season so the signature sheets which is
what I have in my guest room here your
bedroom my bedroom at home they come in
nine colors and they fit all different
mattress sizes and you will feel the
difference the moment you lie down best
of all Bull and Branch gives you 30
night risk-free trials so with free
shipping and Returns on all orders you
can try it you know risk-free you feel
good about it rest easy literally they
also are on a mission to help you sleep
better at night so they're fully
traceable end-to-end sourcing ensures
that the quality and the social
responsibility of the product is premium
because it matters the first 100 organic
fair trade certified bedding company
ever and they're made using 90 less
water than conventional production with
zero pesticides or other toxic chemicals
personally why I'm really drawn to
bowling branches simply because I find
that their sheets keep me cool they're
obviously soft and comfortable and all
that but they keep me cool and I'm a
dark not a dark I'm a deep sweater in my
sleep I'll wake up like drenched with
night terrors and bowling Branch really
helps try the sheets that will make fall
the Cozy season of the year get 15 off
your first set of sheets and free
shipping when you use promo code toast
at bowlingbranch.com that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast for 15 off your first set of
sheets and free shipping promo code
toast yes we love bowling Branch here in
this house actually are sleeping on her
bowl and brand sheets I heard no Leo
slept amazing heard that too that was
the word on the street actually we know
she did because if she didn't she would
be waking up the whole house barking
like an animal like an animal as animals
do next up James Corden breaks his
silence on the restaurant drama says
quote it's so silly as he did quote
nothing wrong so why'd you apologize
The Late Late well we only know what
Keith McNally told us
right up until James Corden speaking oh
so maybe he didn't apologize I mean who
knows but the Late Late Show host broke
his silence on Balthazar owner Keith
McNally's remarks during an interview
with the New York Times to promote his
upcoming Amazon prize series mammals
um as we know McNally had called James
Corden quote the most abusive customer
to my Balthazar server since the
restaurant opened 25 years ago and a
tiny [ __ ] of a man and a tiny [ __ ]
of a man and a follow-up a post hours
later he said that James had apologized
profusely and the ban was lifted James
said to the New York Times quote I
haven't done anything wrong on any level
so why would I ever cancel this
interview I was there I get it he said
now I feel so Zen about the whole thing
because I think it's so silly I just
think it's beneath all of us it's
beneath you it's certainly beneath your
publication during the interview which
was conducted at another New York Eatery
another customer at a nearby table sent
back her eggs watching the situation the
comedian remarked to the journalist can
you imagine now if we just blasted her
on Twitter would that be fair well did
you you yell at anyone he said that is
my point it's insane not him literally
gaslighting us yeah him gaslighting I'm
saying it's beneath you it's beneath me
it's beneath this publication right like
we're not going to talk about it and he
didn't really clear anything up like
is he saying that what Keith said Is A
Lie is he saying he never called and
apologized like what is his version of
the story he's just speaking in like
tongues yeah I mean he makes a good
point though about like okay he saw the
person send back their eggs say was a
celebrity and he could have tweeted you
know Claudia ashrae rudely sent back her
eggs and Bob and like then that just
becomes gospel by the way I totally
approve of that messaging like the way
that people share things about
celebrities or just anyone on social
media like based on their perception
their POV and like how they digested the
situation and then it becomes fact well
not only is it like their truth but they
could also just lie yeah of course of
course uh yeah
um but
I I proved that message like of what
he's saying because I think that part of
our culture is really weird and also the
part where like everyone just accepted
as accepts its as fact there's no way to
prove that it did or did not happen and
then it's just like your word against
this person's right I just don't think
that's the case in this scenario right
because we've also now heard that other
people are saying it also it's not just
like some random person like Twitter
User it's a restaurant or a business
owner he's putting it with his name in
his restaurant like I think it's
different when you're an anonymous
person or you're an anonymous account
you can say whatever the [ __ ] you want
uh completely if you want to show your
face and this is my business and and
here I'll back it all up like and put
yourself out there in the ring with
James Corden I'm more inclined to
believe you than an anonymous person on
like dumois or something right yes so I
agree with James's message but uh this
is not or like uh relevant to his story
at all like he's not a victim here no
and he's being like intentionally
misleading and kind of unclear and
gaslighting US honestly yeah and so it's
like did he apologize to because he says
I did nothing wrong so it's out there
that you apologize like and by the way
what [ __ ] kind of Journalism is this
so you the guy says I did nothing wrong
if I was a journalist I would say Well
then why did you apologize yeah but I
think people were like perhaps they were
surprised that he did the interview but
he was like I've done nothing wrong to
like not do this interview but you know
because like what does that have to do
with promoting mammals right no that's a
fair question and he if he did apologize
to Keith it's like I apologize to this
person over here like what does that
again have to do with this interview
yeah
um I just wish she would be more clear
because honestly he's like speaking very
generally and I don't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about sometimes when people
like speak in such a confusing way they
can get away with a lot no that's what
he's doing now I'm just like well I
don't understand I'm checked out yeah
I'm checked out but I just want to say
for the record like I believe Keith and
I believe that James Corden was rude to
wait stuff yes especially because a lot
of people are now saying the same did
you see that try guy's wife no what um
one of the try guys is why who has
become like why so relevant which is so
crazy because I'd never heard of them no
and like when they did their episode
like what happened I think it was I
don't know I think it was called what
happened it was like top of the podcast
charts which I check all the time and
like when I tell you I had never seen
their podcast before no they should be
thankful to Ned honestly and I
I'm sure they were big before because
obviously like who would have cared so
much about this they were being like a
niche yeah circle like I I didn't
recognize their artwork even you know
you know I know unless it was new
artwork because Netflix
perhaps but a try guy's wife claims that
she saw James Corden scream at a busboy
over a closed restaurant not the wife in
question but Becky habersberger who's
someone else's wife
once alleged once allegedly watched
James Corden scream at an LA busboy she
shared in Tick Tock video detailing the
alleged incident one day after the
Balthazar thing she said I overhear a
busboy telling James Corden that Little
Dom's is closed right now noting she was
walking down the street going to happy
hour when she witnessed the alleged High
raid quote they close in the middle of
the day between lunch and dinner the
busboy is telling James Corden he can
get him a reservation right when they
open he was really trying to be
accommodating she claimed that James
then quote yells at this busboy a lot of
good that does me mate a lot of good
that does me oh see no that's the thing
like you're never rude to a waiter one
time it's like a pattern it's a
personality trait so we knew we said on
Monday when this whole thing happened
like if other people come out of the
woodwork then this is clearly something
that he does and I'm going to believe
Keith and I've seen tons of things
including this now so
right and again this is a person with
nothing to gain yeah like who is a
public figure as well like James who's
not like making [ __ ] up on on like a on
like social media from an anonymous yeah
or like a tick tocker who's like I think
I heard guy this baby crying yeah right
I have no reason to not believe her or
Keith for that matter right so and she
had like very specific details about the
restaurant like no this is and so it
just makes his response
in this interview like all the more
offensive honestly like
either don't address it or just [ __ ]
address it like let's talk about it but
I also feel like this response
which is an interesting tactic in
general because it's like definitely
like defusing the situation I feel like
this response contradicts who he has
pretended to be because the person that
we all thought he was would come out and
be like oh my God I heard someone's
feelings someone's hurt where do I sell
my position
let's do a song you're so right you know
but like in the carpool karaoke yeah
you're so right but this person is like
aggressive yeah you're so right this
doesn't add up with the James we thought
we knew though James he was pretending
to be yeah who would just have been like
oh let's all get along mate bro mate
brub oh my God you're so right you're so
right
you're you know you are so right
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more British drama not Royal
not even close I'm so sorry I shouldn't
have I'm learning about to smack that
[ __ ] iPad out of your head I don't
want to trigger you it's just a lot of
complaints yesterday two Royal stories
they were good like you just um I
appreciate you voicing your opinion and
I do I you're not you're hearing wrong I
hear you but it just like opened up the
floodgates for people like pick apart
every time sorry I'm sorry I bring up
the Royals I'm sorry no you're right you
guys one thing about me is like I can
criticize Jackie you do I'm coming for
your next no like not criticized but
like okay some of the stories you
wouldn't have even noticed that there
was like two Royal adjacent stories if
Claudia like didn't put me on blast no
that's true but you know what like we
just we needed to do better with the
story picking and I feel like we're
working on it you know yeah but also I
think everyone needs to cut Jackie a
little [ __ ] slack because it's hard
to pick stories one that like we can
actually have a an actual conversation
about not being like Oh that's amazing
I'm so happy for them and two uh people
that like [ __ ] we actually care about
people are like I wish you would talk
about I don't know like if we actually
don't care and like are not vested in it
like we're not gonna give valuable
Insight right and also like on any given
day like sifting through stories there's
a lot of things that come in the way
like one
I'm not talking about any Jew hater you
know so Kanye's all over I know I'm not
talking about it either but Balenciaga
did drop him that was the update right
two
um sometimes there's like stories that
conflict with like politics or something
like celebrity we see so we stay clear
of next three a lot of the top stories
are like updates from things that we
spoke about all week like Jason Sudeikis
is on and off again girlfriend throws
shade at Olivia Wilde like no that's the
top of the daily mail today and no I
don't care yeah and now I don't want to
talk about the salad dressing and the
nanny again we talked about it twice
this week yeah so like you have to keep
scrolling down to the bottom of daily
and that's what you get so all I'm
saying is like it's not as easy as it
looks okay yeah it's layered like most
things next Ed Sheeran This is the fifth
Story this is the fourth and you're the
fifth so oh right already Ed Sheeran was
quote hurt actually nervous I feel like
we always do a good job if Claudia
Explains It All no but it's like
requires like literally when I say the
story it'll be one line okay okay Ed
Sheeran was hurt after his James Bond
theme song with scrapped for Billy
eilish sorry hers was so [ __ ] good Ed
Sheeran revealed it hurt to see his
James Bond theme song Shell for Billy
eilish's hit track no time to Die the
hitmaker said he'd already started
writing the song When suddenly he was
replaced by the seven-time Grammy
grammy-winning team Superstar quote they
changed directors and then they just
changed scripts and that was it we had
done all the meetings I started writing
it he said on that Peter Crouch podcast
Peter Krause but he isn't losing all
hope just yet when asked if he would
still be willing to sing the Bond theme
song in the future he said it was a
clear-cut yes yes of course I'm not
going to pretend it didn't hurt not
doing it but yeah I would I think
eventually as an English singer you've
got to eventually do a bond song If they
came back I'd be like yeah of course no
now that I think about it like obviously
to get like fired sacked whatever like
sucks but to an American like is really
tough because it's literally like Sam
Smith Adele
um Chris Cornell Jack White and Alicia
Keys and it's not like an exclusively
British thing but like I'm sure even
bigger on and I'm sure they try to find
someone British yeah and Sam I mean Ed
Sheeran is like
huge and I have a really hot take on Ed
Sheeran
that he's not for you no that's not what
I was gonna say I feel like there was a
period where Ed Sheeran was like the
biggest baddest best most talented
songwriter I saw him in concert I loved
that album I forgot which one it was but
she played the fiddle in an Irish band
and she fell in love with an English man
kissed her on the neck and then I took
her by the hand and baby I just want to
dance like that album was so good
and I just feel like in recent years
he's like really phoning it in like
everything he puts out is trash bad
habits lead to late nights like it's all
just so contrived and like so like
Cookie Cutter pop and I just feel like
like he was is immensely talented like
he puts so much work into the first
couple albums to get to this place of
like super stardom and I was just
phoning it in like
South of the Border with Camila Cabello
like that was a Bop like and now I just
feel like ever since like the last two
three years everything he releases I'm
like this is so like generic you know I
feel that and honestly now I just feel
like what he's putting out is not worthy
of a bond song honestly that's how I
feel I know that took a crazy hot take
come at me but that's how I feel I do
better I think he's worthy of a bomb
song for sure because he has greatness
in him
there's two things that happen one every
song he does like is acted like it's the
best song in the world and it's not and
two even when it is a good song I
honestly don't know because it's played
over and like the shape of You song I
[ __ ] hate and I don't think I ever
liked it no I hate that song too but I
but I'm man enough to admit like at one
point it's a perfect song and that's why
it became so big and then just like
anything you want to literally kill
yourself when you hear it like but like
Castle on the hill I could never hear
too many times because here's the thing
I'm on my way oh it's so [ __ ] good
job like that song makes me want to cry
it makes me want to just like dance no
like especially if you listen to lyrics
so much about like capturing that moment
in your youth where like everything is
going well and you don't even know it
because you're so happy you don't know
how shitty things are gonna get like
it's he has greatness in him because and
castle on the hill is proof of that
perfect
I hate that song but it's a perfect it's
an amazing song you know but it's it's
for me that's how I feel about it like
shape of you like when I listen to shape
of you I'm like I can recognize that
something melodically is like capturing
people like Josie and the Pussycat style
but I [ __ ] am not enjoying myself
what the f word I hate that song I hate
it yeah especially because it came out
same time as Castle on the hill and like
it could have been Castle on the hill we
were listening to all the time but I'm
glad it wasn't because then we would
have started to hate Castle on the hill
never I don't think Ed Sheeran has put
out like something really meaningful
since Castle on the hill for real so
with that said I think he would do I
think if he got the opportunity to do
Bond he would bring his greatness see
but see I don't even think like genre
wise he's the right fit for it like he
is really like little pop man and the
songs are valids they're very me like
they're deep they're Symphonies always
they have like a [ __ ] Orchestra and
he's just a little man with his guitar
like like I wouldn't have John Mayer
write a bond song like it would make no
sense interesting I just don't think
Vibe wise they're a good match honestly
and I think whoever sacked him like did
the right thing not every job is going
to be for you like I would obviously not
be the right person you know to do a
fitness commercial like not everything
is going to work for everyone
okay I think that's I I don't disagree
with you but I think he should have a
bond song in his career well I'm I'm
gonna feed him he's worthy and I think
he would rise to the occasion if he
doesn't I will be mortified he'll be
eating your words because I I actually
don't think it's the right fit for him
the more we like talk it out I actually
think it's not the right move for Bond
and it's not the right mood for Ed move
for Ed okay that's just my thoughts but
you know who should have a bond song The
strikes Brothers Mimi Webb
100 wait let's actually think like who
in current British or or I like the idea
of it being British like
a little man no but it's really it's
it's one person with a really remarkable
voice like that's why Sam Smith's
catalog of music is not that amazing
but he is so supremely talented vocally
like Adele obviously like that's who
we're thinking of like who who has like
a really under like honestly no who has
like a really good singing voice
are we speaking British sorry no Kelly
Clarkson of course yeah it has to be
Kelly that's it I would take anyone from
the Jubilee Mabel Cynthia arrivo
she is a perfect candidate for a bomb
song
Lady Gaga has she done one no her
version of that is tuna I love that no
don't you let go of mine amazing cool
down song after 12. I'm so sorry I've
been in your studio for over an hour I
didn't even realize you have new artwork
that says [ __ ] around and find out that
is so cool it's so cool it's from Scout
I want it that was like right before I
started working with Scout they posted
that on their Instagram and everyone
sent it to me and I got it and I love it
and I had to put in the studio because
it has a swear word on it and I really
they can't have that in my house with
the child oh my god did you just swear
word swear word you're such a cuss word
cuss word I just have to say being in
your home then I'll get to the fifth
Story that I'm about to just like be so
embarrassed being in your home like
seeing how many things like you're
really like I can't say this enough and
I feel like I haven't said it to you and
I really want to tell you like I feel
like you're such a good mom like I just
want to tell you like you do such a good
job and it's so much work and like being
in your house and realizing how like you
have this [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere like
it's so overwhelming it's so consuming I
just want to let you know like you're
doing an amazing job and Zach's like out
of town this weekend at a wedding so
like you're doing so much I just want to
let you know like you're doing amazing
sweetie thank you and I want to be
helpful that's why like I got the I got
them this morning like I want you to
sleep like I want to be helpful I'm here
you know but you won't let me change
your diaper even though like I know how
to do it you like are so cautious the
reason why I wanted to change it this
morning is because usually at one point
in the night I do change his diaper but
I and I didn't last night I let him go
all the way because I thought it would
be good so I wanted to see what was in
there after like the full 12 hours like
Olivia lets me like I'm such a good
diaper changer it was just an experiment
and I was up early and you were still
laying in the dark like let me do it you
know yeah no no no you're right I just
help you I just wanted the the data for
sure for sure no you're a collector of
information at this point yeah but thank
you that's really really nice and you're
an amazing auntie and like it's true
yeah Harry just wants to be entertained
like and he couldn't be have a bigger
Entertainer that's why he and I really
connect like for Michaela I feel like
I'm definitely at like this place in my
life with her where like actually we
actually made huge waves yesterday
because Michaela got a new toy you guys
bonded you found something common ground
it was a Disney karaoke machine and like
she was I'm always like singing and like
much agreeing with her and she [ __ ]
hates it which is my love language it's
like to torture people and for her to
reject that it's really it's been really
tough for me
um but this karaoke machine that she
like was obsessed with and nobody could
figure out how to connect to the
Bluetooth obviously Tech Support over
here I figured it out and then I
obviously had to perform and she's not
at the point where she knows all the
words to the songs yet so she was more
of a viewer than a listener and I think
she was really appreciating my talent
she was and she was having an amazing
time to be appreciated by Michaela which
like honestly I really have never felt
because she's always like please leave
me alone like please leave me alone like
I want to go live my life it felt really
good but you met her on her level of
Moana and Frozen
uh yeah Moana
and then she did sing
me and Margo were like literally both on
the verge of tears it was the cutest
thing ever we were singing
what's the chorus of that song I can
feel you show your uh into the unknown
into the unknown okay and then when it
goes into the unknown into the end she
went like this with her hands and her
mouth
I was gonna die like me and Margo were
not okay it was so cute that toy was
amazing gotta get me one of those yeah I
really do um so they've been about a
story which I'm
just like really like making like a lot
of drama around honestly I'm so I think
everybody's like on the edge of their
seats but like it's not good it's fine
it was going to be just an update Crown
is putting in disclaimer wait you know
what so it's the same Vibe it's yeah it
will be like two little stories how's
that that's good that equals one big
story so uh
the fifth and final very dramatic story
is brought to you by the even better
Clinic clinical serum Foundation from
Clinique their first Foundation designed
to be the last step in your skincare
routine the better clinical serum
Foundation is formulated with three
serum technologies that visibly reduce
dark spots brighten and hydrate the skin
in as little as eight weeks skin appears
more even toned radiant and smoother
even after makeup is removed I feel like
the more experience you get with makeup
the more you hate like putting on
Foundation because it's like really so
bad for your pores it clogs your pores
and you feel like a visible difference
when you take it off and that's why this
Clinique Foundation that is actual
skincare there's three serums built into
it and just a brand like Clinique that
you actually trust it makes you feel so
much better like the older you get
you're not just wanting to put so much
crap on your skin it's like a mask and
your face can't breathe so at least if
you're gonna put something on your face
like let it work for you 100 and
Clinique I've used their skincare many
times and I've been using their
Foundation now for a few months it's so
premium I've definitely noticed a like a
big difference in my skin and the bottle
is so pretty so it like looks nice on
your vanity so to call it a foundation
really doesn't do it justice it's
actually technically a clinical
Foundation is built with three serum
Technologies so it's not just going to
cover your skin it's going to complete
your skin regimen by visibly correcting
hydrating and smoothing the look of skin
with everywhere also the packaging like
I said it's stunning it's also
sustainable because every glass bottle
of the even better clinical serum
Foundation can be recycled you just
remove the cap and the pump rinse the
glass bottle and throw it in the
recycling bin the hydrating Foundation
formula provides buildable coverage it's
medium to full coverage and it has a
satin finish it's really beautiful
um it's I feel like it's good for
daytime but it's also like nice enough
if you are going to like a wedding or
like an actual event like it has real
coverage in it it's also oil free also
oil free waterproof sweat and humidity
resistant non-acnugenic non-caking
non-settling non-creasing non-poring and
non-streaking don't call it makeup it is
Skin Care in your shade find your shade
this holiday season at clinique.com also
the shade matching technology that they
have is supreme
Supreme I got it like I was like there's
no way this works and I like took all
these pictures and I didn't have to get
up it perfect match a perfect use of
technology to actually better Our Lives
um okay so the fifth and final story I
just want to tell you what the
disclaimer is um
inspired by real events this fictional
this fictional dramatization tells the
story of Queen Elizabeth II and the
political and personal events that
shaped her reign
okay so like the bare minimum but like
now Judy Dench actually an acting change
like go Judy go Judy it's your birthday
go Judy no but like I feel like that
could have been on any of the other
seasons and I wouldn't have even noticed
it was like oh thank you for letting me
know this is about Queen Elizabeth right
it doesn't say like we made some [ __ ] up
yeah we made some [ __ ] up it's just the
the word fictional is in here but I feel
like most people like don't wouldn't
register that that's what they're saying
it's something so let's just
be grateful I don't know yeah I whatever
the final story is the bombshell news
that Guy Fieri said in an interview that
he has in fact not only never been to
Ina Garten's house in the Hamptons he's
never even met her how is that possible
they don't have like crossover con uh
the upfronts right like corporate day
out people were really shaken by this
news like and it kind of reflects poorly
on Food Network like your two major
stars like collab and now they have to I
feel like Food Network when it comes to
like social media and stuff they
actually do a good job of like being
relevant even though they're kind of
like like a random Network they're not
like very pop culture but their people
become like such big stars I do feel
like now that this Tick Tock like blew
up because the interview like clipped it
I do feel like we're gonna get a meeting
of the minds it should be like a um a
week-long special like a holiday special
on Food Network like Aina and Guy Guyana
I feel like
we live in two different universes and
one is where Guy Fieri exists and one is
where Ina Garden exists and I don't
think they can actually physically meet
because they're from two different
planets that's a very interesting thing
so they're gonna need a spaceship to get
there right because what happened to
this space-time Continuum if they were
to collide it would be the big bang
and how about I look at this from the
perspective of The Big Bang Theory I
don't know it'd be pretty big it would
be pretty big I just I it's like not
that surprising actually I I they're two
different species no it is surprising
that's like literally working in the
same company starting at the same time
as someone at your company it's a big
company but you both started at the same
time and you've both reached like the
highest c-suite and never meeting them
like Aina films from her house that
happens and he's constantly on the road
I know it's like kind of like a like a
homebound Queen like she's giving
agoraphobia she really is yeah it's like
Jeffrey has to come to her her nephew
Phoebe sometimes in the episode she goes
to the local market she goes to like a
fishmonger no I feel like her bubble
consists of like a three mile radius
around her house like the farmer's
market like just the Hamptons yeah yeah
have you seen her outside of the
Hamptons have you seen her outside of
Bridgehampton no she doesn't go to
Montauk no and she doesn't go to Hampton
Bays
she's exclusively a bridge girly it's
true she's a bridge like she does not
leave the ZIP code
so she has zip code phobia if you could
have
um one person from the Food Network cook
you a meal who would it be
give me a minute to think of all of
you because mine as much as like I love
celebrities and stuff like mine just
from a palette perspective like probably
would be Aina she's not crazy like Guy
Fieri's like always pork belly like of
course no it's not guy it's actually not
Aina though like her oh maybe it's Giada
her yeah aina's meals are just like a
little too fancy and I don't know that
you would love them but I just feel like
if I said Aina if I if I had to make
anyone in the Food Network a roast
chicken I would want I know okay A Rose
chicken fine
fine mac and cheese I'm Michael Guy
Fieri honestly Jihad is a good answer
she's a simple girl simple Italian
Rachel Ray oh didn't get to hang out
with her or Rachel Ray honestly when I
was reading and I would also want Bobby
Flay to cook me something just so I
could tell him it's terrible
I would want Bobby play to cook me
something just so I could be in the same
room with him and I could choke him okay
I'm totally kidding that's not funny
um
when I was reading lessons in chemistry
like they were talking about like the
set of her cooking show I was thinking
so much about 30 minute meals
or yesterday also that like fake TV show
they had in the book supper at six like
that was 30 minutes meant to be like you
start cooking when the show starts and
your meal is done by the show The Time
the show ends and it's like I can cook
something easy or simple it's gonna take
me an hour and a half right you know
right and like now with a DVR like back
back in the day like if you're watching
a cooking show and it was like you were
meant to start the meal with the host
and you would both finish it by the end
like there was no [ __ ] way I'm
keeping up with the host but now with
TBR like I really can do a 30 minute
meal in about 75 minutes speaking of
lessons in chemistry did that book like
make you want to like cook more and then
have more nutritional value in their
meals no if anything it made me like
hate food because she kept saying like
food is Science like shut the [ __ ] up
food is food okay
one the book like really makes me want
to make a spinach casserole and some of
the books that I've read that it
happened to be about cooking like they
do have recipes in the back and I
actually wish that this one did it would
have been the first time I would have
tried it and two my the only flaw with
the book about like cooking is science
it's actually this is what the old adage
is that cooking is Art and baking is
science
Fox you know cooking is meant to be like
a little here a little there sprinkle it
right but when you're baking you need
precise otherwise the whole pie no by
the way
once again you're literally so right so
maybe if she had been an expert Baker
yeah but I did like how she approached
cooking as a science and I think for her
cooking encompasses
cooking and baking so what did you think
about my fifth and final I thought it
was great do you think it's part
interesting conversation I think that it
did look we're still talking about it I
feel he's looking good by the way have
you seen him I think he's like on some
sort of like a wellness because like his
skin is like his youthful glow to him he
looks like he's getting in shape but he
looks like a free idea Guy Fieri should
do another show where he samples like
healthy foods Wellness Trends and lets
us know like what's actually good yeah I
need Guy Fieri to try green juice and
like let me know like what's for real
like I need guy Fiero to go to Erawan
and tell me what to do what's worth it
yeah you know I feel like he would love
arawan at me yeah I've been like twice
but I don't think I fully immersed
myself off the shelves not like prepared
no like that's what you're supposed to
do like oh the stuff off the shelves you
could get at Whole Foods no and it's
literally like 40 for a bottle of olive
oil it's like crazy yeah I feel like I
need to get like some air one you know
behind the counter stuff yeah [ __ ] you
say I gotta get the Smoothie yeah so
like we need this Guy Fieri to go to
what's that place Earth's Earth Cafe
Earth Cafe yeah and like let us know
like all these new things like what's
good
what's good I think that is the content
people want to see and he's the man that
people could trust I would trust him
with my life except like you know I've
only eaten at like a guy's
one of his restaurants one time and I
actually had to spit out my food now in
his defense it was in an airport in
Bogota so like I don't know what the
quality control is like internationally
um and it was an airport restaurant so
you have to lower your expectations but
like I can't actually remember a time in
my life where I've had a chicken tender
that I spit out
so I just want to I just want to be
honest because
everyone has an honest show makes
mistakes everybody has bad days
everybody knows what what I'm talking
about everybody gets that way that's so
true nobody's perfect not even Guy Fieri
no and sometimes I'm in a jam and I
gotta make a plan just you just gotta so
those were the past five stories you
certainly needed to know every iota of
them and this is gonna be I'm glad we
talked about the Fast Five and some of
the landmines that we encounter no I
completely agree because it's like one
thing about us I think that really
separates us from our
um is the level of transparency like
we're really bringing everyone along
with us onto the the business side like
we're showing you what goes into the
artistic process and that's really not
anything you're going to get at any of
those other trash shows so keep
listening to us and [ __ ] everyone else
am I right yeah except for all of our
tmn shows and everything on dear media
um so that is our show I had one more
thing to say oh this is actually because
of the Jewish holidays my tour we
actually haven't done five episodes in
like maybe a month like we've done like
four day weeks and three day weeks
because it was just like some Audio Only
yeah it was like a crazy couple of weeks
so it was nice to finally you know video
audio every five days we've got another
one next week and I believe the one
after that another one next week is your
birthday it was his 30th birthday not
next week sorry yeah
um so
I guess we'll talk about that next week
yeah we'll talk about it and we should
really have a conversation about turning
30. I'm the first one on the podcast to
do it yeah that's thank God for that and
what does it mean sound up in the
comments like what your 30th birthday
meant to you and like what did you learn
what did your 30th birthday mean to you
that's a really good prompt yeah you
want a 500 word essay by the end of the
weekend
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the Millennium Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcasts and where podcasts can be found
so that Spotify iTunes it's your public
radio I already castbox all the places
where we listen podcast find us more
until supervisor review about habitable
setting is where we are I know I said
the morning chest um thank you I'm like
really not taking the Rebrand like it's
not top with mine for me you're not
taking the rerun seriously I guess not
like I didn't even notice you hear that
price your mom is not taking a Rebrand
seriously after all the hard work we put
into it [ __ ] disgraceful I'm sorry
say it with me Bryce your mom is [ __ ]
disgusting I'll do better Bryce love you
guys have an amazing weekend stay safe
and we'll see you on Monday bye